[Music]
misty copeland is one of ballet's
biggest superstars
a child prodigy from an abusive
background she would go on to make
history as the first black female
principal dancer at the american ballet
theatre
she's performed with prince advised
president obama on policy
and was listed as one of the world's
most influential people by time magazine
in 2015.
[Music]
mr copeland welcome to the economist
asks
hi thank you for having me now
i'd like to take you back this time of
year to your
first ever ballet performance you were
i believe about 13 years old and it was
the nutcracker and by my powers of
deduction i'm guessing this might have
been a christmas performance
so what did it feel like
to dance that at the time take us back
to
the 13 year old you well i had
started dancing gosh maybe
six or seven months before i had taken
my first ballet class on a basketball
court
and i had joined the ballet studio on
full scholarship it was the first time
in my life that i felt like i
was a part of something that was bigger
than me that i was a part of something
that
was consistent in my life
that was beautiful that made me feel
strong and that i had a voice there was
a sense of
security and safety around me that i
felt by being a part of the ballet world
by being on stage and you know my my
home environment was really chaotic
there was a lot of moving around there
was abuse
so ballet gave me this this beautiful
bubble that i was existing in
um that you know the worries of having
to go on stage and perform and remember
an entire ballet
that was nothing compared to the
struggles i had already experienced it
by
13 years it showed me empathy
it showed me sympathy it it opened me up
as a human being and i think that the
arts do this in general for people which
is why i think it's so vital for the
arts to be
a part of our you know education a part
of it should be a part of our school
curriculum
um no matter what the art form is 11
years
being the only person of color in the
company we're dancing in and on that
track to be principal dancer and to be
at the top
of your craft how did that
feel and at what point did you ever ask
yourself if you did
why is this the case why am i the rarity
here
when i became a professional
it was a shock it was a shock to my
system i mean of course i was very
cognizant aware of the fact that i am a
black woman
my mother raised me though i'm biracial
i'm black italian and german
both of my parents are of mixed race um
but she raised my siblings and i to
understand that as a black american when
we leave our home
we're going to be viewed as black it
doesn't matter how much black we have in
us that's how we are going to be seen
and treated
so that was a that was understood but as
a dancer
i was just misty this dancer um
so i come to abt and you know there were
a handful of black
male dancers that would come and go and
um
and i was always curious as to why why i
saw them come and go as they did
um and that i was the only woman that
that was there
and um you know it did make me question
everything it made me question why me
i i always thought to myself there's no
way that i
am the best there's no way that i am the
first to come around
that was capable so that's when i
started to
kind of dig in deeper and do research on
my heritage as a black person as a black
american especially in the ballet
culture
and that's when i stumbled upon so many
incredible dancers that
exist and had fruitful careers as far as
their
you know within that time as far as it
could take them you know i think of
raven wilkinson and janet collins
um and then of course lauren anderson uh
with the houston ballet but um
until you're given a true opportunity
which kevin mckenzie at american ballet
theater eventually gave to me
uh you know you're not going to be
written in history books as a black
dancer and that's something i want to
change did you ever feel that you were
held back from
roles by either by your color or by the
perception of your color
absolutely without a doubt um
you know and that's what's so hard for
me because people look at me and um
and will say you know well they're so
their dancers are so much darker than
you like imagine their path and then i
always off
you know i say that um you know it has
to start somewhere
that there's discrimination no matter
how much black you have in you if you
don't have
um pale white skin and fit in with the
rest of the
the group the troop then um you're going
to be seen as other
the first time american ballet theater
filmed the ballet swan lake
um and i was removed from the casting
for being in the second act because i
would have kind of ruined the aesthetic
that's what's said um by being the only
brown
brown person um to you know the line of
court of ballet dancers
um but yeah throughout it's it's you
know dancers of color
often cast as these earthy over
sexualized characters and never seen as
soft and ever seen as
um as ethereal and it's been
you know that's why it was such a big
deal when i was cast as as
the swan in swan lake or you know juliet
in romeo and juliet because black
dancers are never seen
as given an opportunity to be romantic
are there reals where you would say
actually
no i think i shouldn't dance a
particular role because i do think
this really there is something would be
something jarring about having a person
of a certain ethnicity
or do you think we just now have to sort
of say look we're going to be
color blind about casting casting
directors are just going to have to
step up to that in the theater in ballet
in opera
i think that what's so incredible about
ballet
um and why i think it's survived for as
long as it has
is because the purity of the technique
which sees no color
um you know when i think about the idea
behind these are these kind of original
concepts of these ballets
they're they're really representing the
world
you know you think of la by adair in
india and you think of
don quixote in spain so why are all of
these roles being danced by white women
and white men it it doesn't add up so
when they say that
you have to look a certain way to
portray these roles you know a swan
is not a white woman we're creating a
character
so art is fantasy
i think it's beautiful escape a black
woman can't portray the white swan
how do you define that you know none of
it truly makes sense why
is a black woman not capable of being a
fairy are these are like mythical
characters they're not real people um
you know again if a white woman can or a
white man
can portray um you know kind of this
earthy black
character and paint his face black why
can't a black person portray that role
it just there are so many rules that
have been bent that we really have to
um we have really have to open up this
dialogue and really get to the root of
it and address it but would you feel
uncomfortable because you
we would now find blackface in most
forms of art or
comedy or representation to be something
reprehensible
and yet we have had a roles in ballet
that were
conducted like that is that something
that needs to disappear from ballet as
well
absolutely you know i think that it has
slowly gone away for
most companies especially in america but
you know
i think it was two years ago now that i
ended up in
in a social media battle with um with
the bolshoi ballet
because they still do blackface in their
version of la bayadere
in russia you know this this day and age
there are
um there are certain things you know if
you want to be
inclusive and you want the ballet to
continue to be relevant and i know that
this is more of an issue in america
then you can't offend an entire
community of people
blackface has such a deep-rooted
negative history
um so to continue to present that why
would the black community or the
indian community or whoever uh who's
you know being discriminated against or
being offended
why would they want to come and support
the your company why would they want to
come and support
these things so um you know i think of
it as
you know these these monuments that are
being taken down that are just reminders
of
of things you know bad parts of our
history or
you know things that we don't need to
put in front of people's faces
daily you know it's something to put in
a museum put in a history book they're
not something that should be displayed
in in today's culture and time you've
also
worked with president obama you were
advising him on policy around
fitness and also on reaching groups in
terms
of fitness and better body awareness you
might
not otherwise respond to that kind of
public uh
health messaging i mean it's trump you
had a fair amount in common really in
terms of your
background in tenacity and both raised
by very determined
uh single mothers did you find the obama
years to be
inspiring in a way that you think you
can take forward for
young americans particularly young
americans of color but not only or
something that you know we have
then seen an abrupt reversal of
a lot of those gains so i wondered where
you came out having met and worked with
the former president yourself you know i
think that
as much as i see such a positive
growth and change in the ballet world
simply by
my promotion simply by seeing me on the
stage in swan lake and
and in the fire bird as a black woman it
has changed the possibilities and
opportunities and futures for
so many dancers who see themselves
through me
and that's what happened when president
obama became
the first black president of the united
states
um and so for that it you know
it gave america you know a second chance
a new life
to see um future
a future for an entire group of people
um that you know america was built on
our backs
from slavery and this was a new
beginning and so
you know that none of that can be taken
away that happened and it affected
so many people misty copeland thank you
very much for joining us
you can listen to the full interview on
our podcast the economist asks
every week we publish a conversation
we've had with a high profile figure
click the link opposite to enjoy it and
thanks for watching